we will now commence the review Big
Finish time and I'm tackling the one
that I have had so many people from a
long before I got into Big Finish
telling me that I should do spare parts
now I went into this with more than a
little trepidation not that I didn't
expect it to be good everything had
heard indicated to me it was gonna be
good but I've had things over height for
me before specifically in regards to
Doctor Who and specifically in regards
to classic stuff and I know Big Finish
is a little bit different from classic I
do appreciate that but I've had classic
episodes that people you know that I
keep seeing at the top of best of all
time lists and then I see them and I'm
like it was fine because I suffer from
overhype on those things and I really
went into this afraid that I was gonna
deal with the same kind of thing here a
coupled with that is the fact that I
know a fair amount of world enough in
time which was a recent episode that
absolutely loved borrows a lot of
elements or concepts and mood from this
as well so I didn't know if I was gonna
go in not only having to combat height
but having to having to deal with the
fact that maybe I've kind of already
seen this story thankfully though this
is really good really unnerving really
really creepy and it in regards to its
relation to world enough in time it
borrows that that episode borrows a fair
number of the core ideas and definitely
the vibe of the thing but it's not
literally retelling that story and so
the pieces are assembled in a slightly
different manner and also dealing with
different characters because we have the
fifth doctor with Nyssa and that whole
dynamic is completely different from the
doctor and Bill so that also helps
differentiate it quite a bit as well you
can definitely see where the connections
are but one does not feel like a retread
of the other which i think is actually
speaks to the strength of both pieces
now I do try and avoid spoilers when I
talk about Big Finish because I don't
have the same expectation that as many
of my viewers have
heard these audios as I can usually
expect for them to have seen when I
actually talk about a Doctor Who episode
so there are some things I don't want to
talk about that are spoiler but I will
save those for the back end and I'll try
and talk broad right now I'm enjoying
Peter Davison in this and in general I
think I'm enjoying him in the audios
more than at least most of the stuff
that I've seen him in in the show and if
you've seen my ranking of the doctor you
know my feelings Davison in his time on
the show had an artificial 'ti to his
performance that didn't work for me a
lot of his reactions felt very
manufactured they didn't feel
particularly genuine and that's not
necessarily a incorrect way to play the
doctor just didn't work for me and I
think a lot of it might have just been
his youth and sort of where he was as an
actor at the time because the stuff that
I've heard him now on Big Finish is my
second one hearing him or you know even
the short time crash I like what he
brings to the doctor as an older
performer a lot more than then you know
how he connected with me with his time
of the show but but at the same time
feels very much like the same character
so he does really good there's a
wonderful balance of him you know his
sort of his arrogance his aloofness but
also seeing through the cracks in that
and you know his frustration with things
and he's he's able to be he has his
little moments of being witty and and
but he also especially in this story you
feel the the tension of what's going on
because he knows how bad this whole
situation is Nissa coming back was
interesting she's she is a companion
that I know there are I mean I'm still
feeling in my classic who knows there
are some companions I have yet to
encounter at all I do know Nyssa and I
was kind of like Nyssa so it's nice
having her back she works really well
the supporting cast is were also really
really good on this there's sort of
several key supporting cast members
you've got this sort of slightly skeevy
black-market kind of guy called Thomas
Dodd who I really liked I liked his
dynamic he is that kind of slightly
skeevy but you you kind of feel like I
almost said like he has a good heart I'm
not sure
it's true but the situation you he has
human responses he has he has very
relatable reactions to a lot of what's
going on but is also still at the same
time a skeevy guy so there's a couple of
periods where he's paired off with the
doctor that I found their dynamic really
interesting him really intriguing and I
enjoyed him a lot
you've got the Hartley family brother
sister father who are sort of are key
into the the human level of the tragedy
of this story of the origin of the
Cybermen and I'd say that's almost kind
of a spoiler in and of itself but it's
really not because they put a mundus era
Cybermen right on the cover of the darn
thing so you know going in this what
you're getting so you know this is our
key in and the characters we get to
relate to just being on the ground floor
and watching this civilization become
the recurring Doctor Who villains that
we all know and maybe love and maybe are
terrified by so I mean they have a very
clear structural part to play in the
story but they're performed really well
and there are some things that we'll
talk about later on that really do sort
of have a serious impact because you get
to do it through the lens of this family
you've then got some more of you know
your sort of boy I don't know how much I
sympathize with these people because
you've got this woman who's a recruiter
and she finds candidates for conversion
and then you have the actual human being
who is working on creating these
conversions in a is effectively making
the Cybermen and she's really
interesting too because she is just I
mean she is so clearly given up and
she's doing what she's doing because
well what else is there to do but like
she clearly doesn't want to think very
much about what it is she's doing she's
accepted that it has to be done but she
doesn't want to think about it hence why
she is always drinking and again that's
a really fascinating dynamic and it adds
another layer it's another sort of angle
to come at this character and this set
up that I wouldn't necessarily have
expected and it feels more real it feels
more human if I were to compare it with
something like say genesis of the Daleks
which is an episode I haven't reviewed
and I don't know
get around to it because this one I've
already seen and my classes stuff I'm
right now focusing on ones I haven't
seen before but to do it as a comparison
the the genesis of the Daleks story
doesn't feel especially human I don't
mean that as a criticism but the whole
you know military complex of these
people who will be turned into the
Daleks and then Davros as their creator
doesn't feel particularly human it feels
like these are responses in terms of how
they're dealing with things and
certainly Davros particularly where
there's obviously some very twisted and
warped thinking going on whereas here
with the origin of the Cybermen all of
it feels much more human in terms of how
it was we got here which in a way is
what makes it a heck of a lot more
creepy than the Daleks not necessarily
better villains overall but I think the
Cybermen are creepier
especially when Doctor Who focuses on
their origins and how they came to be
because you know enough about the setup
and you understand exactly how we got
here and it's hard to argue that if
humans today were put in a similar
situation that we wouldn't end up with a
similar end result if it was an option
to stave off extinction and of course
we've got Nicholas Briggs doing all the
Cybermen voices and he's just I mean
he's built for this he's great at it so
I'm pretty much all of it works and it's
creeping and it's unnerving and if you
and and also I like at this point having
this now my third audio drama that I've
listened to and I've gotten very much
into the rhythm of it so I'm following
it as a sort of general method of
storytelling better than I did you know
the last few times that I've I've
listened to these that said there's
still a couple of points towards the end
where things do get a little bit chaotic
and it's a little bit you're kind of
going wait what is it that I'm listening
to what's going on and I think sometimes
when they try and recreate the more
action II moments that you expect from
from certain doctor whose stories it
gets a little bit muddled not impossible
to follow but a little bit but that mean
that's pretty minor and
this is this does pretty much live up to
the hype I do say pretty much because I
have some nitpicks but those are gonna
get into spoilers which means I am now
getting to spoilers so if you haven't
heard this yet I recommend take this as
a as my endorsement of it go listen to
it and I'm assuming you've done that or
you have gone away so you're not gonna
get spoiled okay here we go
before I get into my nitpicks that are
involved in spoilers let me talk about
the part of it that hit me the hardest
personally and that is the conversion of
the family member the sister and that
family it Vaughn that hit me really hard
and I was surprised that it did because
I saw it coming I mean you can see it
coming from a mile away and as soon as
you get introduced to this family you're
like somebody in this family's gonna be
converted we know that and as soon as
she gets taken I was like okay it's her
but there's something about the
execution of it and the way that's build
up and that she gets mostly converted
but her programming isn't in place and
she's grasping to what little bits of
her life she can remember and she
wanders back to her home where her
father and her brother and also Anissa
are and there's just this kind of
electronic whimper and the father tries
to connect with her and gets a little
bit because you know she didn't get
fully properly converted but at the same
time it's very clear that his daughter
is dead and he's clinging to a ghost
practically and there is a there's a
dual tragedy to the lingering bits of
humanity that you can hear in those sort
of electronic sobs coming from her and
also the father and then I mean the
brother as well because he sees her and
he had wanted to be converted he didn't
fully understand what it meant for that
to happen but he was jealous when she
got taken away to go through the process
he thought it should have been him
he thought he could be a hero because of
what this society thinks the Cybermen
mean or will mean and that is really
hard and really painful and really
really tragic and probably hits me a lot
harder now than if I listened to it
before I had a kid of my own but as
someone with a kid that yeah that that
choked me up legitimately
and that was that was hard to listen to
in a in a good way in an emotionally
affecting way as far as nitpicks and
complaints the the third of the four
episodes the one I just talked about is
I think the best one the fourth one is
unfortunately probably the weakest and
it's not because the whole thing like
goes off the rails but there are a
couple of moments that end up taking the
wind other thing for me um but again not
massively it doesn't derail it still
works but a bit like how the doctor
Falls felt like a letdown following
world enough in time this last entry in
spare parts feels like a letdown coming
off of the build-up of the previous
three in that third one especially but
it is still good just not as good as
what came immediately before so some of
the moments that kind of like I say took
the wind out of the sails a little bit
there's some weird moments with dr.
Manhattan who's the creator of the
Cybermen effectively like I said I loved
her characterization and the fact that
she's kind of a drunk who's kind of
given up on on the morality of the
situation is she's just gone completely
pragmatic but is basically drinking to
numb her own pain and guilt and and
everything else involved in what it is
that she's doing and everything that's
going on but she has a couple of moments
in Episode four that feel borderline
Davros esque and they feel very out of
place with sort of what came with her
before and they're fairly fleeting but
there's like two or three of them in
that episode so I don't think it's a
fluke they they have a couple of weird
specific moments where she just she just
says things or she tries and work and
she tries to briefly work against the
doctor and it just it
the way it plays out doesn't feel right
for this character and this situation
and with the when what makes these
Cybermen effective that you know they
feel very human in their origins as
opposed to you know like I said with
that verse in the Daleks being based on
Nazis and intentionally feeling very
inhuman when she has little men moments
of I created this I'm like where the
heck did that come from and another
moment that and it was a quick moment
but it kind of made me go
wait what which was a moment the doctor
had and he has a line I may not quote it
exactly but it was something to the
effect of it starts with an artificial
hip and breast implants and where does
it end I'm sorry what and it's one of
those things where and honestly a bit
like oxygen when the doctor said you
know actually calls out capitalism as
the problem and why the scenario
happened it's the same root issue which
is that that point was already there it
was in place it was in the subtext but
when you take the subtext and you make
it text you say it out loud not only are
you sort of losing the strength of
having it just as an underlying message
but suddenly your subtle subtext sounds
stupid
oh when your characters say it out loud
because you know it goes from this thing
that you're implying and it's there for
the audience to make the connection and
go oh so suddenly you just boom you get
it and I hate that I I like I do hate I
hate that line I hate that moment
because it it is making a point with a
sledgehammer that had been made with
such a delicate touch up to that point
just out of nowhere cold and I I was
listening to it and I think it was on my
lunch break at work and that was the the
fact that there were other people or I
was the only reason I didn't go out loud
because I really hated that line but
like I said that is emitted Lee
nitpicking I'm literally getting worked
up about one single
and the thing now it is a line that
frustrates me so much that it's there
that I'm you know it's the sort of thing
that that if this were a movie I'd do a
nitpick rant video on it because it is
just this one thing but I really have
issues with this one thing but I I do
think this is overall pretty much does
live up to the hype and the first three
episodes definitely the fourth one like
is that it dips slightly which is a
bummer but it is still really really
good and the creepiness is absolutely
there and it's at the forefront and yeah
I mean it's it's just well put together
or well performed well written except
for that one friggin line and absolutely
very glad that I checked this one out so
that's it for this month's Big Finish
next month I will be doing a Big Finish
as selected by my patrons because yes
I'm on patreon I'm gonna plug it so sue
me but spare parts have you heard it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it do all
the stuff like subscribe I got a Twitter
and I got a podcast and I mentioned the
patreon already and all that stuff
there's links down below so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]